- [Narrator] Growing up is exciting.
There are so many firsts to discover:
your first word, your first book,
your first day of school,
and with each new thing
you learn, you grow.
At Khan Academy, we embrace
and celebrate learning
at all ages.
We created Khan Academy Kids
to spark the joy of learning
in kids ages two through seven.
Through thousands of
activities, books, and videos,
kids can read, play, learn, and grow.
Narrator Kodi Bear and her friends
guide kids through the app,
encouraging creativity,
curiosity, and kindness.
Because we believe that everyone
should have access to learning,
Khan Academy Kids is completely free,
no ads, no subscriptions.
Khan Academy Kids,
now celebrating first
words through first grade.
Available in the App Store,
Google Play, and Amazon.